make sure this do you care yeah
okay okay so
um you know first my husband and I were
we met through my brother my sister was
engaged in my husband's brother and they
never married so that's a pretty big
bump and then I get pregnant had a baby
gave him up for adoption
that's a really big [__] bump talk
about a bump that's like not a bump
that's like Mount Everest
and then we managed to build the company
have a family you know get married have
a family and have him come back into our
lives that's another big bump every one
of those are hard but the only things in
life you're proud of are the things that
were hard so why not be willing to go do
the hard things